[Musique]
on se cale ça suffit de claquer tout ça
vous êtes un troisième c'est une année
très importante pour vous mais pour ça
il y à quelques règles à respecter lors
de nos qu'une limite tu crois que tu
leur en service pour les gir tous les
élèves d'accord alors on fait un
concours clara temps quand on aime se
fout ouvertement de ta gueule qui dicte
que physiquement tu ressembles office de
trump croisé avec bang non pour moi
c'est de l'irrespect du mot franchement
sur la vie de marc mpay de commandes
je le sais tu as la tête abandonnée tête
devant genk de van gogh d'excusés de sa
prof de maths quand un prof du ps tu
pèses plus de 100 kg saut j'ai de la
marge quand vaut bien un parcours
allez ciao double vie de ma mère la même
tête que van gogh se financer lui même
[Musique]